ROMAN NURIK: Hello and
welcome again to
Android Design in Action.
My name is Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Hey, guys.
Adam Koch.
NICK: Hi.
Nick [? Coche. ?]
ROMAN NURIK: And today we have
way too much content.
So we're just going
to get started.
Today's episode is on the
device automation apps.
The app that we'll be looking
at today is called Tasker.
And then we'll also go into a
deep dive on touch feedback.
And then we have a good
amount of design
use to cover as well.
So let's just get started.
So if we can look at
the slides, Jeff.
I can't really see if
we're looking there.
But I guess we are.
OK.
So this is, on the left
side, the Tasker app.
Now Tasker is basically a
device automation app.
In the app clinic, they kind
of use the term profile,
device profile apps.
This is kind of I guess
a subset of that.
Basically it lets you create
a system of constraints or
contexts and create a set
of actions or tasks.
I guess tasks are collections
of actions in this app that
get run when the device
enters that kind of
profile, that context.
So, for example, if the week day
is Monday through Friday
and the time of day is between
9:00 AM and 5:00 PM, you can
be thought as in the
work profile or in
the work set of contexts.
And then so once you enter that
context, rather enter
that profile-- there's a lot
of terminology in this app.
It's somewhat confusing.
But it's very well
thought out.
When you enter the context,
certain things can happen.
When you leave that context
or profile,
other things can happen.
So there's an Enter
and Exit action.
So that's at a very high level
what the app does.
It lets you had to do a number
of different things from
setting system settings
automatically, to speaking out
text, to doing all sorts
of interesting things.
And then of course, the number
of different profiles or
different constraints that they
have is also very large.
So you can really, really
customize the set of
behaviors you want.
So this is the app.
As you can see here, there's
kind of these three tabs--
profiles, tasks, and scenes.
I'm not really going to talk
about scenes that much.
Because I honestly didn't
really get a feel
for what they were.
But profiles and tasks
are two of the most
important things here.
So here we have a
single profile,
which is my work profile.
And on the left, you see the
different contexts that need
to be satisfied to be
in this profile.
And then on the right hand side,
you see basically the
actions that occur when
you enter or exit.
In this case, there's only
an enter action.
So when you exit this profile,
when you leave work basically,
nothing will happen.
There won't be an unmute
or anything.
NICK: And it's set to unleash
a panda as soon
as you get to work.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
I couldn't really find a
better icon for muting.
Unfortunately, the built an
icons didn't really have a
really obvious mute icon.
So I just chose a panda.
Because they're cute
and cuddly.
NICK: OK.
ROMAN NURIK: And basically
here there's
some standard stuff.
There's these actions in the
bottom that let you add
things, add a profile in this
case, accept and cancel
changes, turn Tasker on
and off as a whole.
And then to edit things on the
screen, there is a lot of long
pressing going on, which
if you look through our
guidelines on gestures you
should really reserve long
press for other things.
But there's a lot of complex
interactions and a lot of
stuff going on on this screen.
So that's why we chose to
think of a kind of a
re-imagining of what
it could look like.
Before I jump into
the redesign,
Nick, Adam, any thoughts?
NICK: Yeah.
This app's been on my radar
for quite some time.
I think they won one of the
early Android developer
challenges.
And I think the features you
described are super powerful.
But I've always been put off.
Whenever I get to the place,
to a listing, and you see
their screenshots, it's very
intimidating looking.
Like I have no idea what all the
different controls refer
to and the plethora of options
it seems to offer up.
So I was pretty excited that we
got to take a look at this
application and try and make
all that power perhaps a
little easier to tap into.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, absolutely.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
We'll just move on.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
So let's look at the redesign.
So this is the re-imagining
of the Tasker home screen.
So on the right hand side--
I'm just going to zoom in
here so you can see.
On the right hand side
here, we have Tasker.
And obviously we've
refitted it with--
wow.
Saying refitted sounds
like exhibits--
what's that kind of car
refitting show that he had?
NICK: "Pimp My Ride."
ROMAN NURIK: "Pimp My Ride." It
sounds like pimping rides
or anything.
But whatever.
So we've refitted it with--
NICK: Is like a plasma
screen TV is going to
[? fall down the side. ?]
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
We've done a plasma screen TV.
OK.
We should really fly
through this.
Because we have way
too much content.
Anyway so we've fitted
it with the standard
action bar and tab bar.
We've basically taken their core
tab bar that they've had
in the previous screen here.
And we've made it look more
hollow obviously.
We feel these tabs are
probably fine.
Separating out the app into
these three core sections is
probably OK.
It's really up to the app to
decide what their information
architecture is.
But we left it as it.
And we've moved the on, off
switch for the entire app to
the top right as a key action.
In this case, some could argue
that you shouldn't have
actions in both the top right
and in the split action bar.
But in this case, it's really
kind of like a global--
it's not really an action.
It's really like a toggle, like
a high level toggle for
the entire app.
So we felt that it was
appropriate there.
And then in the content of the
screen, you see your profiles.
But here you can't really
edit the profiles.
And this is one of the things
that I found that was a little
confusing with the current app
is that viewing the list of
profiles and editing an
individual profile is all in
one screen.
It'd almost be like seeing a
list of contacts and editing
each contact all in one.
It's almost like
a spreadsheet.
And it just felt overbearing.
So we decided to split this
screen up into two screens,
where on one screen you see
the list of profiles.
And you can obviously turn them
on or off, which is a
simple action that
you can take.
But then to edit the profile,
you touch once to
get into the details.
And we'll show you that.
So here you see the
list of contexts.
This is called my mute
at work profile.
And there's the list of contexts
or constraints that
need to be fulfilled.
And then when you
enter, it mutes.
And when you leave,
it unmutes.
And then here is an example of
a profile that's turned off.
For example, send, I'm coming
home, as a text message.
And we've decided to
turn that off.
And there's no exit action.
There's only a single
enter action there.
And then you could add a profile
using the standard
action bar action there.
And then there's another feature
inside of the menu,
deep in there somewhere, which
was Search Tasker, which--
I don't exactly know
what it did.
But it was just kind of like a
global search through the app.
We decided to expose that as an
action in the bottom left.
Before we move on,
any comments?
Should we fly through,
keep going?
OK.
Let's keep going.
So in the same exact screen that
you saw in the beginning,
you see this kind of both
viewing a list of profiles and
editing the profile screen.
This is the editing portion
that we broke up into a
separate screen, where here you
see the profile itself,
the enter and exit actions
that you can
select using a spinner.
And then there's a little
shortcut here to edit each of
these tasks.
And again, a task is a
collection of actions which
we'll see a bit.
And then to add a context or add
a constraint, you simply
would press this in
line Add button.
And of course, you could
put this in the
action bar if you want.
But this is just an assortment
of different types of ways you
can expose this.
And then to remove something,
you just swipe to dismiss it.
And there are probably other
actions you can take on each
individual context.
For example, editing should
just be a one touch thing.
But if you want to duplicate it
or clone it or something,
maybe that can be exposed
through an overflow
affordance.
And obviously if you want to
delete multiple things, you
should allow for multiple
selection using contextual
action bar.
OK.
The next screen--
this is an example of
selecting a task.
So when you exit this mute at
work profile, here are the
list of things you could do.
You can say oh, there's
no exit task.
Or you can browse all tasks and
manage tasks where you can
select one of the existing
ones that you have there.
Pretty straightforward,
nothing fancy there.
On the next screen, this is
basically where you are
editing a task.
And you can see here, there are
a lot of objects that you
deal with in this app.
And so one of the core points
overall with this redesign is
to simplify things, to make it
very obvious what you're
working with.
And so here you're working
with a list of
actions for a task.
And previously you were
working with a list of
contexts for a profile.
So you want to make it very,
very clear throughout every
step in the process what the
types of data you are working
with is and where in the
structure it is.
So here is another example of
how you can kind of use swipe
to dismiss and a simple Add
Action here at the top to
replace a bunch of buttons
that are on screen for
deleting and adding and
things like that.
And actually here you'll notice
that there's no real
way to delete something.
You have to long press
to delete.
It seems kind of like extra
work to have to do that.
I think there's probably
one or two more.
This is the place where you
can kind of rename a task.
So if you jump into the task
details, you should be able to
edit everything.
And one of the ways you could
do that is to have an inline
text field with the name.
So you just start changing the
name right there and then.
Or if you don't think that
that's going to be a very
common thing, you could move it
into the action overflow as
kind of a rename additional
action bar.
And I think the last screenshot
I want to show here
is adding an action.
This is one of the more
important parts.
So actually this is adding
an action, not a context.
So when you add an action, like
when I am at work for
example mute the phone or speak
some text or whatever,
airplane mode or whatever.
To do that in the current app if
you have to kind of go into
a browse mode where you see this
overwhelmingly large set
of things you can do.
And it's kind of hard to really
find the thing you're
looking for.
And I think in this case,
you're generally more in
search mode rather
than browse mode.
So I think that it would be a
better case here to basically
have an auto complete.
So if I'm in the list of actions
to take, I just start
typing volume or mute
or something.
And it gives me a pre-populated
auto completed
list of things that I can do.
And as soon as I touch,
it just adds it.
And if there's configuration
stuff, then it just shows the
configuration stuff.
So I think that was it.
I know that was super fast.
We went through that
in 12 minutes.
Anything else you guys want to
say before we move on from the
screen redesigns?
NICK: I really like the way it
feels a lot cleaner now.
I think generally dialogues
just aren't the answer.
The previous app popped up a lot
of dialogues, which kept a
lot of contexts and a lot of
load of the user to kind of
remember where they are.
And I feel like the new setup
with the before and after-- it
just feels a lot easier
to use for me.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
And this app in general is
just really complicated.
It does a lot of things.
And so I think breaking the
different functions into
different screens really, really
helps the user navigate
through these different
sections.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And really in this case
it's simplifying.
And actually there's a lot of
cases in the past where we've
combined the multiple
screens into one.
And I think that this app can do
well by splitting things up
more since it's so complex.
Before we jump to the touch
feedback session, I just want
to briefly talk about some
iconography, well actually I
guess branding.
And actually it's really
just branding,
this umbrella of branding.
This is the current
icon on the left.
And here's kind of what it could
look like matching the
redesigned theme.
So the redesigned theme is
kind of a blue and orange
color scheme.
And so here's what it
could look like
with that color scheme.
And this better fits some of the
other app icons that are
out there just purely in terms
of styling, not so much in
iconography which is kind of the
most important thing to be
memorable is, what
is in the icon?
But to make it feel a little
more modern and up to par with
some of the other apps
that are out there.
And then the last thing I want
to mention is the lack of a
feature graphic.
You cannot be featured,
absolutely cannot be featured.
The editorial team for Google
Play will do nothing with your
app in terms of promotion
unless you
have a feature graphic.
So make sure that you add one.
And this is just one example
of what a feature graphic
could look like for Tasker.
It could be as simple as just
having your name and the icon
there, maybe a tag line
or something.
But make sure that it's also
legible and clearly delivers
the message at small sizes.
Because this feature graphic can
appear in very, very small
sizes on phones and
other devices.
NICK: Yeah.
Just to expand on that
just a little bit.
Yeah.
Like Roman says, this one,
same, large asset--
it's like 1024 pixels wide
when you supply it.
And so people get tempted
to cram all kinds of
information in there.
But really, really
resist that.
Because it can be shown
very, very small.
If you think about a small
handset, kind of three inches
diagonally handset, it's going
to be shrunken down greatly.
So my advice to people
is always to get
your feature graphic.
And resize it down to about
100 pixels wide.
And check that everything's
kind of legible and still
looks good at that
kind of size.
And the other tip is that if
you are lucky enough to get
featured, the graphic can be
shown in the Play store on the
front page without
much context.
So I always find it's helpful
to have your feature graphic
convey some of the meaning
of what the
application actually does.
Because they're going to see
it on its own without the
benefit of the title and the
description text and the
screenshots.
So really have it kind
of stand alone.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And it could appear without
the icon and
appear without the title.
So absolutely.
That it can appear standalone
is a very, very important
point for future graphics.
NICK: And resist putting
screenshots in there.
Because they don't
size very well.
And also [INAUDIBLE]
[? put a device ?]
frame in it.
It just has the ability to
look dated very quickly.
So try and resist that.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
All right.
Shall we move on to
touch feedback?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Adam, you want to drive?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, sure.
So we wanted to discuss
a little
bit about touch feedback.
We actually look at
a lot of different
applications in our role.
And surprisingly, one of the
things we see broken in a lot
of them is touch feedback,
which is strange.
Because it really does give
the user a sense of
responsiveness and indicate
that something's happening
within the application.
And the amount of effort
required to actually add good
touch feedback in your
application is
actually not that much.
So it's definitely something
with lower amounts of effort
that has great pay off.
And of course the canonical
source for information on
touch feedback is
the design site.
So if you just go on to style,
there's a section
called touch feedback.
We'll cover this on
the next page.
There's a bunch of states here
and some more information on
some recommendations of how you
should actually style the
different states for
touch feedback.
But we have some tips I think
on the next screen.
Yeah.
So the first thing to remember
is all interactive elements
should provide feedback.
Not some of them-- every single
one should provide some
sort of feedback.
ROMAN NURIK: They say if it does
something, it should look
like it does something
when you press it.
ADAM KOCH: Exactly.
And another point to make is
you should be consistent.
So we often see people
customizing touch feedback for
parts of the application.
But then they don't go and
customize, say, the action bar
touch feedback.
So you have sort of the holo
blue in the action bar.
But you have a completely
different color scheme for the
rest of your application.
ROMAN NURIK: And one that one
thing that can help with that
is the Android holo colors
website, which basically
generates all that for
developers, as well as the
action bar style generator,
which again does all that for
the [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
Combining that will really
help you get sort of 99%
through your application,
being consistent there.
We'll touch on this
again in a second.
But you should really ensure
that the full touchable target
area has feedback, so not
just the portion of it.
If it's touchable elsewhere, it
should really have feedback
across the entire item.
As we mentioned, customized ad
feedback for custom components
and whatnot.
And also, don't forget about
the multi select mode and
contextual action bar.
Those are really important
modes.
And you should really make
sure that there's touch
indicators when you're in
the multi select mode.
So we've got some examples.
And we can discuss some
of these points on
the next slide here.
ROMAN NURIK: It'll load.
And there it is.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
So this is just some of the
system apps to start with.
We've got Google+ on the left,
YouTube in the middle, and the
system gallery on the right.
So one area I see a lot of
people leaving out touch
feedback is when they're fully
customizing a list view.
So you've got this long
scrolling list of items.
And they've really
customized it.
So in the case of Google+,
they've got these
sort of nice cards.
YouTube-- it's almost like
a card-like interface.
But it's sort of rich items
showing the YouTube thumbnail.
And very frequently, we'll see
people forget to add the
different states to these
kinds of list views.
So there's two, sort of,
different types here that
these apps have taken.
In the Google+ app, for example,
they've sort of
covered the entire item in a
sort of blue highlight, a holo
blue highlight.
I quite like that.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
That's kind of like
an overlay.
And in development terms, it's
basically the draw selector on
top attribute on list views
and grid views.
ADAM KOCH: Correct.
And in the YouTube app, they've
gone and sort of shown
the overlay, a sort of
[INAUDIBLE] overlay.
They've gone and showed
it underneath the
main thumbnail there.
So it's another approach
you can take.
It's really up to you
which one to choose.
Personally, I like the Google+
method a little bit more.
But when you've got rich
graphics in your list view, it
really comes down to how you
want to display it here.
And then the third screen
shot shows the gallery.
And it's got the contextual
action bar activated.
And you can see, again, it's got
the touch feedback there.
So that when you select each of
these, it shows a nice sort
of blue holo overlay.
ROMAN NURIK: And actually you
get a lot of this for free
using on Android 4.0, well, on
ICS and above, you get this
for free with, I think,
the selectable
item background attribute.
So if you use that throughout,
you don't even have to custom
create all these assets,
these blue assets.
It just comes with the system,
with the framework.
So it's really, really useful
to just use that, to
just drop it in.
Android, colon, background
equals this.
Or Android, colon, foreground
equals the selectable item
background thing.
And you get a lot
of it for free.
ADAM KOCH: Correct.
NICK: It's also included in the
support library, right?
ROMAN NURIK: Is it?
That's awesome.
That's great.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
I guess it's with [INAUDIBLE]
as well.
Like a standard list view-- if
you use the standard list
items, it will have touch
feedback for you.
But it's only when you really
customize these
things that it may not.
Because you're building the
layouts from scratch.
NICK: Yeah.
So I think the key thing is here
is if you're customizing
you're providing your own button
drawables and stuff
like that, make sure
you include all the
custom states as well.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And it's a selector drawable
or a stateless drawable.
ADAM KOCH: It is.
ROMAN NURIK: So here you have
XML along with your PNG's that
indicate which PNG file, which
nine patch, or whatever should
be used with each state.
NICK: And while you're in there
creating your kind of
press states, remember
to also include the
focus states as well.
Because devices with trap falls
and Google TV's and so
on will really, really benefit
from those states.
So while you're at it,
do the right thing.
ADAM KOCH: Yes, correct.
And as I mentioned, on the
design side it has some
examples of how you should
color and style those
particular different states.
NICK: Well just use
[? Andrew Holoco's ?].
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
So here's an example of a
third party app, the Ted
application, which we
like to use as an
example here on the show.
There's three different
screens here now.
It's kind of hard to see
in the first screen.
But there's a grey highlight
actually on the top left part
of the action bar as well
as on the tabs.
I kind of double tapped here
just so we could fit it into
one screenshot.
ROMAN NURIK: You just contorted
your hand in there.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
It was kind of hard to take a
screenshot at the same time.
But they've got a sort of light
grey highlight here when
the user touches down.
And then if you look at these
other screenshots next to it,
you'll see for other items,
including the action items in
the action bar--
yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: So we should
move it into view.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, sure.
Let's move it here.
They've got a red highlight.
So they've got two different
highlights.
And they kind of use them for
different items across the
application.
So places, I guess, where they
are already using the sort of
trademark Ted red
color, they'll
use the grey highlight.
And other places, they'll
use the red highlight.
So for example, in this button
here, which says, listen to
this talk, they've got the
red highlight again.
And this comes back to that
point we were talking about
where you should really
highlight the
entire touchable area.
So you'll see here that the
whole red highlight is
covering the entire line.
Because you can touch anywhere
across that entire line.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So the first time you touch
it, you'll probably touch
around the icon or the text.
But then when you see that the
rest of that row responds in
red, your brain will internalize
the fact that this
whole thing is a single object
that you can interact with.
So it really helps make
that association.
ADAM KOCH: Yep.
And I think we should move on.
Because we're low on time.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
ADAM KOCH: And then finally
two other types of touch
feedback worth mentioning--
there's boundaries and
communication.
So if you look here at the left
screenshot, it's kind of
hard to see.
If you get the slides after the
show, you'll be able to
see it a bit easier.
But this is showing the edge
resistance, when you swipe
down and there's nothing more
above the current list.
So you've got this sort of blue
glow showing here at the
top left in Google Play.
NICK: It's like a force field
you just run up against.
It starts glowing.
ROMAN NURIK: It's dissipating
energy as its kinetic energy
is turning into light
basically.
For developers out there,
this is the edge effect.
And edge effect compat classes
that let you do
this on custom views.
ADAM KOCH: And of course, using
standard views, you get
all of this for free.
It is worth remembering how it
looks and how it behaves.
Because you don't want to have,
say, blue colors at the
top there that might be
clashing with it.
NICK: But it's quite interesting
that if you use an
app when you can see that
they've implemented their own
kind of horizontal paging
[? we're often ?] using, so
another view page component.
And it doesn't give you
that feedback when
you've reached the edge.
It just kind of feels
off, right?
ADAM KOCH: Mmm hm.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
ADAM KOCH: Definitely.
ROMAN NURIK: For sure.
ADAM KOCH: And then in the
second screenshot, it's the
Gallery application.
And when you swipe to the edge
here, it kind of has a 3D
effect where all of the
different thumbnails kind of
tilt to the side, again
showing resistance.
So this is more of a custom
implementation, I guess.
So you can definitely implement
something custom.
It's really up to you.
Personally, I like the
blue glow, as we've
been talking about.
But depending on the feel of
your application, the gallery
is very much of a 3D sort of
feel of an application.
So that's what's it's sort
of appropriate here.
And Launcher has something
kind of similar as well.
But the whole thing tilts.
And then finally,
I just wanted to
quickly mention this.
And this is fairly advanced.
I can't imagine that many app
developers doing this.
But there's this concept
of communication,
so for touch gestures.
So in this example, Gmail--
you've got the sort of swipe
to delete or swipe to archive.
As you swipe, you'll notice the
actual item starts to fade
out slowly as you move
across more.
And if you slide back again
without actually completing
the swipe, it'll fade
back in again.
So this is just sort of hinting
to the user that this
item's going to go away as you
swipe it off the screen.
So, again, this is
pretty custom and
probably more advanced.
But definitely something to
think about if you have these
advanced gestures.
All right.
We'd better keep moving.
We've got five minutes left.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
So let's fly through Android
design news.
ADAM KOCH: [INAUDIBLE]
ROMAN NURIK: We have like
six or seven items.
But let's start with the
redesigns of the Outlook.com
map by Taylor Ling and Sam
Nolte from holo there.
Really awesome work.
Sam even basically did
a multi pane UI.
He did a whole bunch of
different screens.
And Taylor also kind of had
his own take on this app.
And you'll notice that actually
there are some
similarities.
There are some very obvious ways
to map an older app to
the newer holo style.
And this is just one example of
minor variations of that.
And I think that they're both
really good jobs there.
Let's fly through to
actually Uhani, in
response to their redesigns.
He also did a post on the
[? alog.com ?] map.
And basically he gave some
anecdotal feedback, actually
some real feedback, I guess,
with some real data on how
when you release an app that
is using older, kind of
gingerbread, even eclair,
donut styling, for newer
devices, meaning now if you
released that sort of app now,
users are going to respond very
negatively towards that.
So be careful while doing
that if you're
thinking about doing that.
NICK: Just don't do that.
ROMAN NURIK: Just don't.
ADAM KOCH: It's a easier
way, yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: And then one of
the folks that submitted an
entry for the stencil giveaway
a few weeks ago, Gen Gal--
he did a couple UI mock-ups
for the Dribble app or for
what Dribble could look
like on Android.
It's pretty cool.
Nick, you want to add
anything about this?
NICK: Just that I want this.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
I saw your comment, just want,
exclamation point.
Yeah.
I feel the same way.
NICK: Says it all, right?
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
Next up we just released
yesterday the new version of
the Maps API for Android.
This is V2 of the API.
It requires Google
Play services.
And that's all you
need really.
There's no separate bundle
or anything.
It's really just part of
Google Play services.
And this is basically if you
want to get vector tiles and
3D building facades and all of
this cool new 3D maps stuff in
your app, you should definitely
switch over to this
from the original map view.
And this also works with
fragments and support library
fragments as well.
So you get a lot of
the benefits.
Basically everybody's
asking for this.
And finally we're able to--
ADAM KOCH: The big
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK: So for designers, I guess
the key takeaway is you
can now have maps kind of
throughout the application.
Developers have complained
and said, oh, that's
really hard to do.
That's no longer the case, as
well as having some pretty
advanced features as well, so
having custom overlays and
different shapes and boundary
boxes and so on and so forth.
This really, really allows lots
of really, really cool
interactions with maps.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
I'm really excited about the
different angles and panning
and tilting that you can do.
I think that's going to work
really nicely with some of the
apps that are out there.
ROMAN NURIK: And remember,
you can design
custom marker icons.
So the marker icons don't have
to look like the teardrop
shape or a little
circle shape.
It could use your branding
if you want.
It could be custom
shape or whatnot.
So lots of options there.
And there's this new website,
Androidviews.net, which
basically has a list, a
collection, of different
custom views and different
UI widgets and things.
And this is kind of similar to
the ultimate Android library,
which is more broadly scoped.
It covers libraries that are
for image caching and all
sorts of stuff.
But this is very specific
to UI widgets.
And it's a very nice
presentation of the different
UI elements you can
use in your app.
NICK: It's very pretty.
But I'm not sure about
that icon.
It's like a steaming Android.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
That's exactly what it looks
like, a steaming Android.
He's very angry.
NICK: OK.
Next.
ROMAN NURIK: And, Nick,
you want to talk
about Marie's post?
NICK: Yeah.
So basically Marie is a regular
viewer and active
designer in the community is
trying to get the community of
Android designers to kind of
coalescence and speak to each
other a bit more.
I certainly resonate with
this kind of idea.
I think when we were doing the
design competition, there was
a ton of activity going on on
Google+ especially where
people posting on
the hash Android
design and the hashtag.
And that was really cool.
I'd really like to see
that continue.
So Marie is trying to get
everyone together.
So if you find this QR code
and comment on her thread,
she's trying to put together a
circle of developer designer
working with Android.
So comment on the post.
And we'll try and share that
around, so everyone can kind
of connect to each other
and start talking
about Android design.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
So we're at 11 o'clock.
Let's fly through the last
couple of things.
I recently did a blog post
on designing for tablets.
So if you're designing for
tablets, which means hopefully
everybody that's watching,
check out this blog post.
It will link you to things that
you may not have seen
before, definitely kind of a
good resource for designing
for tablets and even developing
for tablets.
And lastly, we recently put
out a developer survey.
So if you're an Android
developer and you haven't
filled out the survey and you
are thinking, I really wish
that the Google Android team
could do this, this, or this,
fill out the survey
and let us know.
Thank you.
And I think that's it for
stuff for this week.
As always, I am Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Adam Koch.
NICK: Bye.
Thanks.
Nick Coche.
ADAM KOCH: Thanks, guys.
ROMAN NURIK: See you guys.
ADAM KOCH: See you later.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
See you next time.
Peace out.